maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum information at computation ang pangalan ko ay John Watrous at ako ang teknikal na
direktor para sa edukasyon sa IBM Quantum ito ang ika-eth na aralin ng serye at ito ang huling aralin sa
ikalawang yunit ng serye na tungkol sa Quantum algorithms napag-usapan na natin ang query model ng computation kasama na ang Quantum
algorithms na nag-aalok ng mapatunayang mga kalamangan kumpara sa mga klasikal na algorithm sa loob ng modelong iyon napag-usapan natin ang mga pangunahing konsepto na konektado sa
Quantum algorithms at kung paano natin masusukat ang computational cost at sa nakaraang aralin napag-usapan natin ang phase estimation at ang algorithm ni Shore
sa araling ito tatalakayin natin ang algorithm ni Grover na nagbibigay ng quadratic na kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa
mga klasikal na algorithm para sa tinatawag na mga unstructured search problem na ipapaliwanag ko kapag nakapasok na tayo sa
aralin ang lahat ng ito ay mga pangunahing paksa tungkol sa Quantum algorithms may ibang mga Quantum
algorithm din pati na rin ang mga pangkalahatang paradigm na nag-uugnay ng iba't ibang Quantum algorithm at mga Quantum algorithmic technique at
kung interesado ka hinihikayat kita na tingnan ang quantum algorithm Zoo na nag-kategorya ng mga kilalang Quantum algorithm at naglalaman ng maraming sanggunian
sa mga orihinal na research paper na nag-ambag sa kanilang pag-unlad para sa seryeng ito gayunpaman
mananatili lang tayo sa mga pundamental at simula sa susunod na aralin lilipat tayo sa bagong paksa pero
una pag-usapan muna natin ang algorithm ni Grover narito ang pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin magsisimula tayo sa maikling talakayan ng
computational problem na tatalakayin natin na unstructured search sa madaling salita maaari mong
isipin ang unstructured search problem bilang paghahanap sa isang koleksyon ng mga item na hindi nakaayos at hindi nakahanay sa isang kapaki-pakinabang na
paraan pagkatapos ay tatalakayin natin ang algorithm ni Grover na isang Quantum algorithm na nag-aalok ng quadratic na kalamangan kumpara sa
mga klasikal na algorithm at malalaman natin ang eksaktong ibig sabihin nito sa madaling salita ang napakataas na antas ng paglalarawan ng
kung paano gumagana ang algorithm na ito ay mayroon munang hakbang ng initialization at pagkatapos ay isang operasyon na tatawagin kong
grover operation na inuulit ng ilang beses at sa wakas ay may sukat na nagaganap na nagbubunyag ng kandidato
na solusyon sa search problem ipapaliwanag ko kung ano ang grover operation at kung paano ito maaaring
ipatupad sa isang quantum computer at pagkatapos ay dadaan tayo sa pagsusuri ng operasyong ito para mas maunawaan kung ano ang ginagawa nito at kung bakit ito kapaki-pakinabang para sa
paghahanap ang ikatlong bahagi ng aralin ay nauugnay sa bilang ng mga ulit
sa algorithm ni Grover o sa madaling salita ang bilang ng beses na dapat ilapat ang grover operation sa pagpapalagay na nais nating
i-maximize ang posibilidad na magtagumpay ang algorithm sa paghanap ng anumang hinahanap natin habang pinapaliit din ang
gastos nito magsisimula tayo sa natatanging search problem na isang espesyal na kaso kung saan may eksaktong isang solusyon sa ating
search problem at pagkatapos ay isasaalang-alang natin kung ano ang mangyayari kapag mayroon ng maraming solusyon at sa wakas ay magtatapos ako ng
aralin sa ilang maikling puna tungkol sa algorithm ni Grover at ang mga generalization nito simulan natin ang
computational problem na tatalakayin natin sa buong aralin una tulad ng madalas nating ginagawa gagamit tayo
ng Sigma para tukuyin ang binary alphabet at gagamitin natin ang notasyong ito para sa buong aralin kaya hindi ko na ito paulit-ulit na
banggitin ipagpalagay nating mayroon tayong function f na nag-mamap ng mga binary string ng ilang haba na n papunta sa
binary alphabet ang ating pagpapalagay ay madali tayong makakasuri ng function na ito
halimbawa marahil mayroon tayong Boolean circuit para sa function na ito na ang laki ay polynomial sa N ngayon hindi ito nangangahulugan na ito ay
isang simpleng function sa anumang paraan o na mayroon tayong partikular na magandang pag-unawa sa function na ito halimbawa marahil mayroon tayong
medyo kumplikado at magulo na Boolean circuit para sa pag-compute ng F na nagpapahintulot sa atin na suriin ito sa iba't ibang input string ngunit hindi kinakailangang mayroon itong
magandang anyo na dinisenyo para gawing mas madali ang ating buhay ang ating layunin ay makahanap ng solusyon na ibig sabihin ay
isang binary string ng haba na n na nagpapasuri sa F sa isa sa pangkalahatan ito ay napakahirap na
computational problem o kahit papaano ay pinaghihinalaang napakahirap lalo na kung ang input ay sa katunayan ang
paglalarawan ng isang Boolean circuit para sa pag-compute ng function na f ito ay isang tinatawag na NP complete na problema isang paraan
upang i-formalize ang problemang ito ay bilang isang query problem at sa katunayan para sa layunin ng araling ito makatuwiran
na isipin ang problemang ito nang eksklusibo sa konteksto ng query model ngunit kapag iniisip natin kung saan o kailan ang
problemang ito ay maaaring lumabas sa praktis mas natural na isipin ang f bilang isang function na kinukuwenta ng isang Boolean
circuit tulad ng nakita natin sa aralin anim gayunpaman maaari nating ikonekta ang dalawang pananaw na ito sa pamamagitan ng konstruksiyon na dumaan tayo para sa pagkuha ng Boolean circuit at
pag-convert nito sa isang Quantum circuit para sa pagpapatupad ng isang query operation o isang query gate sa anumang kaso sa konsepto
ang input sa problema ay ang function na f at naghahanap tayo ng solusyon kung mayroon man at kung
wala namang solusyon na ibig sabihin ay lumalabas na ang F ay constant zero function ang tamang output ay iulat
na walang mga solusyon ito ay isang unstructured search problem sa kahulugan na walang
espesyal tungkol sa F na nagpapadali ng paghanap ng solusyon hindi tulad ng naghahanap tayo
sa data na nakaayos na o nakapaloob sa isang data structure na nagpapadali ng paghahanap at walang pangako sa
function na f na maaaring tumulong sa atin isang paraan para isipin ito ay parang paghahanap ng isang partikular na
numero ng telepono sa isang direktoryo ng telepono kumpara sa paghahanap ng pangalan na mas madali sa pagpapalagay na ang mga pangalan ay
nakaayos nang alphabetically sa praktikong paraan hindi talaga ito tungkol sa paghahanap sa data
na madalas nating inayos at inimbak sa paraang nagpapadali ng paghahanap mas kinakatawan ito ng paghahanap ng
solusyon sa isang kumplikadong equation halimbawa o marahil paghahanap ng kombinasyon na nagbubukas ng isang
kandado bilang karagdagan makatuwiran na isipin ang problemang ito sa konteksto ng query model anuman ang ating
pakiramdam tungkol sa praktikal na kaugnayan ng modelong iyon siyempre walang mga oracle o blackbox sa tunay na buhay ngunit hanggang
hindi natin nalaman kung hindi tayo mapagkompiyansa ang mga kumplikado at mahiwagang Boolean circuit ay parang mga black
box ngayon pag-isipan natin ang mga algorithm para sa paglutas ng unstructured search problem na ito at gagawin natin ito
sa query model para lang sa kapakinabangan ng simplisidad kung mayroon tayong Boolean circuit para sa ating function sa halip na isang black box
maaari pa rin tayong magpatakbo ng mga query algorithm dito ngunit siyempre hindi natin maitatapon ang posibilidad na ang ilang bagong algorithm
ay natuklasan para sa problemang ito na hindi batay sa paggawa ng mga query ngunit hindi tayo mag-aalala sa
posibilidad na iyon una kaunting notasyon lang ang kabuuang bilang ng mga input string sa function na f ay 2 sa
maliit na n kung saan ang maliit na n ay ang haba ng mga input string sa F at mula rito itatakda ko ang malaking N bilang numerong ito na 2 sa
maliit na n karaniwan na ang mga tao ay gumagamit ng malaking titik katulad nito para tukuyin ang dalawa sa kapangyarihan ng maliit na
bersyon ng titik na iyon tatalakayin natin ng maraming beses ang malaking N kaya ito ay magiging
maginhawa at makakatulong na panatilihing maayos ang mga bagay at muli ang notasyong ito ay may bisa para sa
buong aralin ngayon siyempre maaari nating malutas ang search problem nang klasikal sa pamamagitan lang ng
pag-ulit sa lahat ng posibleng end bit string sa anumang pagkakasunod-sunod na pinili natin na sinusuri ang F sa bawat isa
sa kanila kung makahanap tayo ng solusyon sa anumang oras maaari tayong huminto ngunit sa pinakamasamang kaso ay susuriin natin ang F sa bawat solong
input string kaya nangangailangan ito ng n na ibig sabihin ay malaking N
query maaari tayong pumili na sukatin ang gastos ng computasyong ito sa ibang paraan hindi lamang sa mga tuntunin ng bilang ng mga query ngunit ang bilang ng mga query
ay kumakatawan sa bilang ng mga beses na kailangan nating suriin ang function na f at makatuwiran na asahan na ang mga pagsusuri ng f ay magiging dominante sa gastos
ng computasyong ito ito ay sa katunayan ang pinakamahusay na magagawa natin gamit ang isang deterministic na algorithm
at muli ito ay sa konteksto ng query model kung na-query na natin ang bawat input
string maliban sa isa at ang F ay kumuha ng halaga na zero sa lahat ng mga ito hanggang ngayon paano tayo makatitiyak na ang huli
ay solusyon at ang sagot ay hindi tayo makatitiyak kaya kailangan natin ang lahat ng n query sa pinakamasamang
kaso maaari rin tayong gumamit ng Randomness na maaaring mag-alok ng ilang napakaliit na pagpapabuti tulad ng pagbabawas ng
inaasahang bilang ng mga query na kailangan para makahanap ng solusyon kapag mayroon man o maaari tayong epektibong mag-trade ng katumpakan ng
posibilidad para sa pagbabawas ng mga query ngunit anuman ang iyong diskarte kailangan pa rin natin ng bilang ng mga query na linear
sa N kaya sa klasikal na paraan kailangan natin ng linear na bilang ng mga query na ibig sabihin ay linear
sa malaking N ang algorithm ni Grover ay isang Quantum algorithm para sa paghahanap na mas mahusay nito nangangailangan lang ito ng bigo ng
square root ng n query ang mga query na iyon ay nangyayari sa superposition kaya hindi ito mahiwagang karunungan ngunit ito ay
isang makabuluhang pagpapabuti kumpara sa posible nang klasikal at ito ang ibig sabihin ng quadratic
na kalamangan maaari bang ang quadratic na kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa klasikal ay maging isang aktwal na kalamangan sa praktikal
na kahulugan malamang na hindi sa lalong madaling panahon ngunit sa malayong kinabukasan sino ang makakaalam ngunit kahit
kung ang algorithm ni Grover ay hindi kailanman makapagbibigay ng praktikal na kalamangan para sa paghahanap ito ay gayunpaman isang mahalagang bahagi ng
pundasyon ng quantum algorithms na sulit na maunawaan bago tayo lumipat sa algorithm ni Grover mismo kailangan nating
pag-usapan nang maikli ang tinatawag na phase query gate maraming Quantum algorithm sa query model ay natural na ipinapahayag
gamit ang mga phase query gate at makikita natin na ang algorithm ni Grover ay isang espesipikong
halimbawa simulan natin sa mabilis na pagtingin sa mga ordinaryong query gate para sa isang function na f ng
anyo na pinag-usapan natin ang query gate na UF ay tinukoy sa mga standard basis state tulad ng ipinapakita sa
screen at para sa mga superposition ng mga standard basis state ang aksyon ay tinutukoy ng linearidad at sulit na paalahanin
ang ating sarili na mula sa isang Boolean circuit para sa f maaari nating talagang bumuo ng isang circuit para sa operasyong UF sa gastos na
linear sa laki ng Boolean circuit ang phase query gate para sa f sa kabilang banda na tatawagin nating
ZF ay gumagana nang ganito lalo na ang gate na ito ay gumagana sa
maliit na n na qubit kumpara sa maliit na n plus isa na qubit at ito ay awtomatikong naglalagay ng function value
sa phase sa halip na i-xor ang output value sa isang karagdagang qubit tulad ng mayroon tayo para sa
UF kaya kung iniisip natin kung ano ang mangyayari kapag ginamit natin ang phase Kickback sa isang UF gate
iniimplementa lang natin ang isang ZF gate kailangan natin ng minus state at nagagastos ito ng isa
na pagsusuri ng UF ngunit talagang maibabalik natin ang minus state at maaari nating gamitin ito para sa susunod kung gusto natin o
maaari nating itapon ito kaya iyan ang isang phase query gate ngayon kung
binibigyan lang tayo ng isang phase query gate na ZF at ito ang tanging paraan na mayroon tayo ng access sa function na f hindi natin talagang
mabubuo ang isang UF gate ngunit kung mayroon tayong controlled na bersyon ng ZF maaari nating
buuin ang isang UF gate at iiwan ko ang isa sa iyo bilang isang
ehersisyo bukod sa phase query gate para sa function na f kailangan din natin ng isang phase query gate para sa nbit
or function o sa madaling salita ang function na kumukuha ng halaga na zero kapag binibigyan ng l0o string at kung hindi ay
kumukuha ng halaga na isa at partikular ang paraan na gumagana ang zor sa mga standard basis state ay ipinapakita
dito sa screen ang gate na ito ay walang anumang depende sa function na f kaya hindi ito nangangailangan ng
anumang query at isang paraan upang bumuo ng isang Quantum circuit na nagpapatupad ng operasyong ito ay ang paggawa ng isang bagay
katulad ng ginawa natin para sa function na f maliban na nagsisimula tayo sa isang Boolean circuit na nag-compute ng or function sa
n bit at ngayon na mayroon tayo ng mga gate na ito handa na tayong lumipat sa susunod na
seksyon ngayon tatalakayin natin ang algorithm ni Grover simula sa paglalarawan ng algorithm nagsisimula tayo sa pag-initialize ng
maliit na n qubit sa plus state o sa madaling salita inilalagay natin ang mga qubit na ito sa equal superposition ng lahat ng
binary string ng haba na n ang gagawin natin ay epektibong ituturo ang estado ng mga qubit na ito
patungo sa isang solusyon kaya natural na simulan natin sa estadong ito dahil wala pa tayong alam tungkol sa function na f
sa puntong ito bawat string ay pantay na malamang na maging isang solusyon at ito ay makikita sa katotohanang ang mga qubit na ito ay nasa equal superposition ng lahat ng
string at pagkatapos ay umuulit tayo paulit-ulit tayong nag-a-apply ng grover operation na talaga ang puso ng
algorithm at ipapaliwanag ko ito sa ilang sandali inilalapat natin ang operasyong ito ng kabuuang T beses kung saan ang T ay ilang hindi negatibong
integer ngunit ang bilang na ito ay hindi aktwal na tinukoy ng algorithm mismo kailangan nating pumili ng T kahit papaano at sa susunod na
seksyon ay pag-uusapan natin ang mga magagandang pagpipilian para sa T ngunit sa ngayon maaari nating isipin ang bilang ng mga ulit na ito na t bilang
arbitrary at sa wakas ay sumusukat tayo sa standard basis at nagbibigay sa atin ng isang kandidato
na solusyon walang garantiya na ito ay isang solusyon ngunit kung pipiliin natin nang mabuti ang T
ang posibilidad na makakuha ng solusyon ay maaaring gawing malaki at narito ang grover operation
mismo na pinangalanang G ito ay komposisyon ng mga operasyon lahat ng mga ito ay nasa N qubit kaya ito ay isang N
qubit na operasyon una mayroon tayong ZF gate o sa madaling salita isang phase query gate para sa
input function na f sinusundan ng isang layer ng mga Hadamard gate at pagkatapos ay mayroon tayong zor na siyang phase query gate para sa or
function at sa wakas ay isa pang layer ng Hadamard gate kaya makikita natin na ang isang ulit sa
hakbang dalawa ay maaaring ipatupad ng isang circuit na may anyo na ipinapakita dito sa screen at mayroon tayong apat na qubit dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan
ngunit sa pangkalahatan maaari tayong magkaroon ng anumang bilang ng qubit isang mahalagang bagay na dapat tandaan dito ay kailangan natin ng isang query ng f upang maipatupad ang G
kailangan natin ng isang query upang maipatupad ang ZF at wala sa iba pang mga operasyon ang may anumang dependence sa F kaya hindi sila nangangailangan ng anumang query kaya ang bilang na T na
kumakatawan sa bilang ng mga beses na inilalapat natin ang G sa hakbang dalawa ay kumakatawan din sa bilang ng mga query na
kailangan natin narito ang isang karaniwang paraan na maaari nating gamitin ang algorithm ni Grover ngunit ito ay tiyak na hindi ang tanging paraan tulad ng sinabi ko
bago ang unang bagay na kailangan nating gawin ay pumili ng T at tatalakayin natin iyon sa susunod na seksyon
para sa anumang T na pipiliin natin tatakbuhin natin ang algorithm ni Grover para sa T na ulit at makakakuha tayo ng kandidato
na solusyon na X walang garantiya na ang X ay talaga ay isang solusyon ngunit maaari tayong gumastos ng isa pang karagdagang query upang suriin kung mayroon tayong solusyon maaari nating
i-output ang solusyon na iyon at huminto at kung hindi ay maaari tayong subukan muli posibleng may ibang pagpipilian ng T
ngunit hindi kinakailangan o maaari tayong sumuko at iulat na walang anumang mga solusyon tulad ng sinabi ko bago ito ay
hindi ang tanging paraan na maaaring gamitin ang algorithm ngunit ito ay isang natural na paraan ng pag-apply nito sa search problem susunod ay makikita natin kung ano ang grover
operation na talagang ginagawa sa estado ng N qubit na kinakakilos nito isipin natin ang ating n qubit bilang
isang solong register na tatawagin kong Q para lang pumili ng pangalan tandaan kung ano ang ginagawa natin una sa
algorithm ni Grover ay ilagay ang Q sa isang uniform superposition ng lahat ng nbit string at ginagawa natin iyon sa pamamagitan ng paglalapat ng Hadamard
gate sa n qubit sa all zero state pagkatapos ay inuulit natin ang grover operation G at pagkatapos ay
sumusukat magiging kapaki-pakinabang na paghati-hatiin ang set ng lahat ng nbit string sa dalawang set na a z at
A1 ang a zero ay naglalaman ng lahat ng string na nagpapasuri sa F sa zero at ang A1 ay naglalaman ng lahat ng string na nagpapasuri sa F
sa isa isa pang paraan para sabihin iyon ay ang A1 ay naglalaman ng lahat ng solusyon sa ating search
problem habang ang a z ay naglalaman ng lahat ng hindi solusyon lalo na
interesado tayo sa dalawang Quantum state isa ay ang uniform superposition sa lahat ng hindi solusyon iyon ay k a z at
ang isa pa ay uniform sa lahat ng solusyon at iyon ay kat A1 dapat kong ituro na ang mga kahulugang ito ay
makatuwiran lamang kapag ang mga set na ito ay hindi walang laman dahil kung hindi ay isinasama natin ang zero na bagay at hinahatian ng zero at habang
tinatahak natin ang pagsusuring ito ng algorithm ni Grover gagawin natin ang pagpapalagay na iyon maaari nating madaling malaman kung ano ang
ginagawa ng algorithm ni Grover kapag ang f ay alinman sa constant zero function o ang constant one function sa pamamagitan ng pagtrato sa kanila bilang mga espesyal na kaso ngunit iiwan ko iyon
para sa iyo na gawin nang ikaw mismo hindi nakakagulat kung bawat string ay isang solusyon talagang makakakuha tayo ng
solusyon kapag sumusukat at kung walang mga solusyon ay hindi tayo makakakuha ng isa dahil sa kasong iyon ay wala naman
ngunit para sa layunin ng pagsusuring ito ipagpapalagay natin na ang parehong mga set na ito ay hindi walang laman upang ang
mga kahulugan ng dalawang estadong ito ay makatuwiran sa pamamagitan ng paraan ito ay medyo karaniwan
notasyon tuwing mayroon tayong hindi walang laman na finite set na s maaari tayong sumulat ng c s upang mangahulugang ang uniform superposition sa
mga elemento ng set na iyon tulad ng mayroon tayo dito kaya tipunin natin ang mga kahulugang ito nang ganito at makikita natin kung paano sila kumokonekta
sa algorithm ni Grover ang unang hakbang ng algorithm ni Grover ay ang hakbang ng initialization na naglalagay sa Q sa isang uniform
superposition sa lahat ng nbit string at para lang bigyan ng madaling makilalang pangalan ang estadong ito tatawagin ko ito
na kat u kung saan ang u ay maikli para sa uniform mahalaga para sa layunin ng pagsusuri na una nating tandaan na
ang uniform na estado na kat u ay nakapaloob sa subspace na spanned ng dalawang vector na k a0 at k
A1 lalo na kung kukuha tayo ng linear combination ng dalawang estadong ito na ipinapakita dito sa screen ay makukuha natin ang kat
u ngayon ang susi sa buong pagsusuri ay ang katotohanang ang estado ng Q ay nananatili sa
dalawang dimensional na subspace na ito gaano man karaming beses nating ilapat ang grover operation kaya lahat ay mapapaikli
sa kung ano ang mangyayari sa isang dalawang dimensional na subspace ngayon tingnan natin kung ano ang ginagawa ng grover operation at lalo na kung ano ang
ginagawa nito sa mga vector sa dalawang dimensional na subspace na spanned ng kat a0 at kat
A1 makakatulong na isipin na ang g ay nahahati sa dalawang bahagi ang isang bahagi ay ang ZF
gate at ang isa pang bahagi ay ang zor gate na nakalagay sa pagitan ng dalawang layer ng Hadamard
gate narito ang kahulugan ng ZF mula bago at medyo direkta mula sa kahulugang iyon na makita ang
aksyon nito sa ating dalawang estado ang mga uniform superposition ng hindi solusyon at mga solusyon ay simpleng maglagay ng minus sign
sa harap ng kat A1 well walang nangyayari sa kat a0 at iyon lang ang kailangan nating malaman
tungkol sa ZF para sa layunin ng pagsusuring ito para sa ikalawang bahagi na
ang Z or gate na nakalagay sa pagitan ng dalawang layer ng Hadamard gate simulan natin sa pag-alala kung paano tinukoy ang zor isang paraan para isulat ito
ay tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen ito ay parehong expression tulad ng dati at isa pang paraan para ipahayag ito gamit ang direct
na notasyon ay ganito at maaari mong i-verify ang expression na ito sa pamamagitan lamang ng pag-iisip kung paano ang operasyon sa
kanang kamay ay gumaganap sa mga standard basis state lalo na walang ginagawa nito sa all zero state at bawat
iba pang standard basis state ay nakakakuha ng minus sign na sang-ayon sa kahulugan ng Z
or kaya kung i-sandwich natin ang operasyong ito sa pagitan ng dalawang layer ng Hadamard gate makakakuha tayo ng katulad na expression maliban
na sa halip ng all zero standard basis state mayroon na tayong uniform superposition na k u at iyon ay dahil ang H tensor
n ay nag-transform ng L zero standard basis state sa k u at ang H tensor n ay sarili nitong conjugate transpose kaya gumagana ito nang katulad
na kumikilos mula sa kanan sa bra sa halip na sa kat at ngayon ay malaman natin kung ano
ang ginagawa ng G sa ating dalawang vector na a0 at A1 gamit ang mga katotohanang katatapos lang nating
obserbahan simulan natin sa a0 muna i-substitute natin ang expression
na nakuha natin para sa Z or gate na nakalagay sa pagitan ng dalawang layer ng Hadamard gate susunod maaari nating gamitin ang katotohanang ang ZF ay walang ginagawa
sa kat a z kaya maaari nating alisin ang ZF operation at ngayon gamit ang paglalarawan
ng kat u na mayroon tayo dito kasama ang katotohanang ang k a0 at k A1 ay mga orthogonal unit vector maaari nating kalkulahin
ang product ng bra na ito dito at ng kat na ito at ang nakukuha natin ay ang square root ng bilang ng hindi solusyon
na hinati sa n maaari nating gamitin ang katotohanang ito upang suriin kung ano ang nakukuha natin at sa pamamagitan ng pag-substitute ng ating expression para sa kat u at
simplifikasyon ay makukuha natin ang panghuling resulta na ipinapakita dito sa screen lalo na pansinin na ang
vector na ito ay nakapaloob sa dalawang dimensional na subspace na spanned ng k a0 at k A1 tulad ng iminungkahi ko bago at
bukod doon ang mga coefficient ay mga totoong numero tulad ng palagi i-verify ito sa iyong
sariling bilis kung pipiliin mong gawin iyon madalas akong dumaan sa mga ganitong bagay nang mabilis sa mga video na ito na may
inaasahan na i-pause mo ang video para pag-isipan ito kung pipiliin mong gawin iyon kaya linisin natin ito upang
mai-save natin ang panghuling resulta para sa bandang huli at ngayon ay gagawin natin ang katulad para sa vector na k
A1 maaari nating gamitin ang parehong expression ng G tulad ng dati at sa pagkakataong ito ang ZF gate ay nag-inject ng
minus sign na dito ay makikita sa katotohanang pinalitan natin ang dalawang term sa operasyon sa
panaklong pagkatapos ay nagpapatuloy tayo sa napaka-katulad na paraan at ang panghuling resulta ay katulad maliban na ang dalawang coefficient
ay pinalitan at ngayon ay mayroon tayong minus sign sa harap ng isa sa kanila na iyon lang ang paraan ng pag-gana ng algebra at muli ay maaari
mong suriin ito sa iyong sariling bilis pansinin na muli ay mayroon tayong real linear combination ng ating dalawang vector na k a0 at
k A1 linisin din natin ito at ilalagay natin ang panghuling resulta kasama ang isa pa at ngayon ay makikita natin kung paano kumikilos ang G
sa subspace na spanned ng ating dalawang vector isang paraan para gawin iyon ay ipahayag ito sa mga tuntunin ng 2x2 matrix na M na
ipinapakita dito sa screen at para lang maging malinaw kung ano ang ating ginagawa dito inaasosasyon natin ang unang row at ang Una
column sa k a0 at ang ikalawang row at column sa kat A1 sa ngayon sa serye ay
ginamit lang natin ang mga matrix para ilarawan ang paraan ng pag-gana ng mga operasyon sa mga standard basis state ngunit karaniwan na gumamit ng mga matrix
para ilarawan ang mga aksyon ng mga linear map sa iba't ibang set ng vector hindi lang mga standard basis state at dito ay pinag-uusapan natin kung ano ang ginagawa ng operasyon G sa
mga vector na k a0 at k A1 maaari tayong magsabi ng higit pa tungkol sa ginagawa ng G sa mga vector sa
span ng k a0 at k A1 kung titingnan natin nang mas malapitan ang matrix na M na ito at lalo na ang mahahanap natin ay
na ang m ay isang rotation matrix na ibig sabihin ang aksyon nito sa dalawang dimensional na espasyong ito ay maaaring ilarawan bilang isang pag-ikot ng ilang
nakapirming anggulo mayroon dalawang iba't ibang paraan para makita ito at isa ay obserbahan
na ang matrix na M na ito ay maaaring ipahayag bilang kwadrado ng isang matrix na mukhang medyo mas simple maaaring mahirap itong mapansin kung
tinitingnan lang natin ang M mismo ngunit hindi ito isang bagay na kailangan nating matuklasan nang mag-isa kailangan lang nating i-verify ito at maaari nating gawin iyon sa pamamagitan ng simpleng
pagkwadrado ng matrix sa kanan isa pang paraan para isulat ang matrix sa kanan hindi kasama ang kwadrado ay
ipinapakita sa screen at ito ang karaniwang paraan para ilarawan ang isang pag-ikot ng isang ibinigay na anggulo na Theta bilang isang
matrix ang tiyak na anggulo kung saan tayo umiikot ay ang inverse sine ng square root ng bilang ng
mga solusyon na hinati sa n at sa pamamagitan ng paraan dahil ito ang unang pagkakataon na makikita natin ito pansinin ko na
ang anggulonng ito ay napakahalaga ito ay patuloy na lalabas habang tinatahak natin ang
pagsusuring ito ang argumento ng inverse sine ay isang numero sa pagitan ng 0 at 1 at partikular ang paraan ng ating
interpretasyon ng inverse sine dito ay ang anggulo sa pagitan ng 0 at Pi / 2 na nagbibigay sa atin ng argumento kapag kinuha natin ang
sine kaya iyon ay isang paraan para isipin ang matrix na ito na na-kwadrado natin para makuha
ang M at dahil ang pagkwadrado ng matrix ay katulad ng pag-apply nito nang dalawang beses makikita natin na ang M ay maaaring isulat nang kahalintulad bilang isang
pag-ikot hindi ng anggulonng theta kundi ng dalawa * Theta dahil sa pamamagitan ng pagkwadrado ay umiikot tayo ng anggulo ng theta
nang dalawang beses isang ibang paraan para i-verify ang lahat ng ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan kung sakaling makakatulong ay simulan sa panghuling expression ng M
at gamitin ang mga double angle formula mula sa trigonometry upang makuha ang orihinal na expression ng
M at ito ang expression ng M na naglalarawan ng aksyon na mayroon ang g sa subspace na spanned ng k a0 at k A1 na
magiging pinaka-kapaki-pakinabang sa pagtahak pabalik sa algorithm ni Grover mismo pagkatapos ng
hakbang ng initialization ngunit bago tayo magsagawa ng anumang application ng G ang estado ng ating n qubit na register Q ay kat u ang
uniform superposition sa lahat ng nbit string at narito ang parehong expression ng kat u sa mga tuntunin ng k a0 at
k A1 tulad ng dati ngunit ngayon na natukoy na natin ang anggulonng Theta nakikita natin na maaari tayong
isulat nang kahalintulad ang k u bilang cosine Theta * k a 0 kasama ang sin Theta * k
A1 malinaw iyon para sa coefficient ng k A1 at para sa isa pang coefficient kailangan lang nating obserbahan na ang laki ng a0 kasama ang
laki ng A1 ay n at pagkatapos ay makukuha natin ito mula sa ilang pangunahing trigonometry kaya iyon ang estado na
pinasimulan natin at ang unang pagkakataon na nag-apply tayo ng G ay umiikot tayo ng anggulo ng 2 * Theta kaya ang kabuuang anggulo ay nagiging 3 *
Theta at kung nag-apply ulit tayo ng G ang anggulo ay tumataas sa 5 Theta dahil epektibo tayong umiikot ng karagdagang
anggulo ng 2 Theta at iba pa kaya pagkatapos ng T na application ng G maaari nating katawanin ang
estadong makukuha natin tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen kung saan ang anggulo ng ating estado ay katumbas ng 2T + 1 * Theta iyon ay 2 * Theta
para sa bawat application ng G kasama ang karagdagang Theta dahil iyon ang estado na pinasimulan natin
maaari rin nating isipin ang aksyon ng grover operation sa geometric na paraan at nakakatulong ito na magbigay ng ilang liwanag kung paano
gumagana at kung bakit ang epekto nito ay ang pag-ikot ng estado ng register na Q narito ang pangunahing ideya ang grover
operation ay komposisyon ng dalawang bahagi na natukoy na natin isa ay ang ZF at ang isa pa ay ang z or na nakalagay sa pagitan ng
dalawang layer ng Hadamard gate ang dalawang bahaging ito ay
mga refleksyon at kapag kinokompose natin ang dalawang refleksyon ay nakakakuha tayo ng pag-ikot kaya tingnan natin kung paano ito gumagana sa
mas detalye una ay ituon natin ang pansin sa ZF at rerestriktahan natin ang ating pansin sa
parehong dalawang dimensional na subspace na pinag-usapan natin na ibig sabihin ang isa na spanned ng kat a0 at kat
A1 tulad ng naobserbahan na natin ang aksyon ng ZF sa espasyong ito ay medyo simple ito ay
walang ginagawa sa kat a z at naglalagay ng minus sign sa harap ng k A1 ito ay isang refleksyon at partikular
ito ay isang refleksyon tungkol sa linya na parallel sa k a0 na tatawagin nating L1 para lang
bigyan ng pangalan upang makita kung bakit ito ay isang refleksyon makakatulong na gumuhit ng larawan narito ang ating dalawang vector na k
a0 at k A1 na mga orthogonal unit vector at maaari nating isipin ang screen bilang binubuo ng lahat ng real
linear combination ng dalawang vector na ito kaya ang bilog ay kumakatawan sa lahat ng unit vector kung saan ang mga coefficient ng
dalawang vector na ito ay mga totoong numero narito ang linya na L1 na parallel sa k a0 at kung isasaalang-alang natin ang ilang
arbitrary na vector s sa bilog na ito ang epekto ng pag-apply ng ZF ay ang mag-reflect tungkol sa linyong ito tulad ng ipinapakita sa
screen dahil lang walang ginagawa tayo sa k a z at naglalagay tayo ng minus sign sa harap ng k
A1 sa espesyal na kaso na ang s ay k a zero halimbawa walang nangyayari kapag ginagawa natin ang refleksyon at kapag ang s ay
k A1 ang refleksyon ay dala tayo lahat ng daan patungo sa negative na k A1 at iyon ay katulad ng aksyon ng ZF kaya ang ZF ay isang
refleksyon na maaaring mailarawan tulad ng mayroon tayo dito ang ikalawang bahagi ng G na siyang z or
na nakalagay sa pagitan ng dalawang layer ng Hadamard gate ay maaaring ipahayag bilang 2 * k bru minus ang identity matrix tulad ng
naipakita na natin at muli ito ay isang refleksyon sa pagkakataong ito tungkol sa linya na L2 na parallel sa k u sa halip na k
a0 maaari nating mailarawan ang operasyong ito sa katulad na paraan sa ZF narito ang vector na k
hypothetically kaya ito ang linya na L2 na parallel sa K at muli ang aksyon sa isang arbitrary na vector S ay ang mag-reflect
nito tungkol sa linya na siyang L2 sa kasong ito
at sa wakas tulad ng nabanggit ko bago tuwing kinokompose natin ang dalawang refleksyon ay nakakakuha tayo ng pag-ikot at partikular ito ay
isang pag-ikot ng dalawang beses ng anggulo sa pagitan ng mga linya ng refleksyon kaya iguhit natin ang katulad na
larawan sa dati narito ang mga linya ng refleksyon na may anggulonng Theta sa pagitan
ng mga ito at kung kukuha tayo ng ilang arbitrary na vector s na na-reflect sa unang linya na L1 at
pagkatapos ay na-reflect tungkol sa ikalawang linya na L2 ang net na epekto ay ang pag-ikot ng vector s ng anggulo ng dalawang beses ng Theta
at ito ay isang bagay na totoo sa pangkalahatan at maaari mong subukan ito sa ilang karagdagang halimbawa nang ikaw mismo upang makita na ito ay talagang ang paraan ng
pag-gana nito anyway sana ay makakatulong ito sa iyo na makakuha ng ilang intuisyon kung bakit ang grover operation ay may epekto ng pag-ikot ng
mga vector susunod ay haharapin natin ang isyu ng pagpili ng bilang ng mga ulit na T sa algorithm ni Grover
simulan natin sa pag-iisip kung paano ang pagsusuri na nakita natin hanggang ngayon na nagbubunyag kung ano ang ginagawa ng grover operation
kapag inilapat natin ito nang paulit-ulit sa uniform superposition ay nauugnay sa gawain na inaasahan nating malutas na siyang makahanap ng solusyon sa ating search problem
o sa madaling salita anumang string na nakapaloob sa set na A1 sa madaling salita ay ittatakda lang natin
ang isang target at pagkatapos ay malaman kung ilang beses na ilalapat ang grover operation upang malapit sa target na
iyon una ay isipin natin na mayroon tayong anumang estado na isang linear combination ng ating dalawang vector na k a0 at k
A1 kung magsasagawa tayo ng standard basis measurement sa estadong ito makakakuha tayo ng resulta sa set na A1 na siyang
set ng mga solusyon sa ating search problem na may posibilidad na katumbas ng absolute value squared ng anumang coefficient na mayroon tayo para sa k A1 at para sa
vector na ipinapakita sa screen ang coefficient na iyon ay beta ito ay intuitive kung susukat tayo ng estado na k a0
makakakuha tayo ng random na hindi solusyon at kung sumusukat tayo ng k A1 makakakuha tayo ng random na solusyon kaya kung susukat tayo sa estadong
ito dito makakakuha tayo ng random na hindi solusyon na may posibilidad na absolute value ng Alpha squared at ng random na solusyon
na may posibilidad na absolute value ng beta squared ngunit maaari rin tayong maglaan ng sandali para kalkulahin ito narito ang estado na nakasulat
nang maliwanag upang makita natin kung ano ang mga entry ng vector na ito para sa mga standard basis state kaya kung susukat tayo ang mga ito ang
mga posibilidad na makuha ang bawat posibleng resulta at upang makuha ang posibilidad na makakuha ng solusyon ay isinasama natin ang
mga posibilidad para sa lahat ng posibleng solusyon na nagbibigay sa atin ng absolute value ng beta squared tulad ng
inaasahan ngayon ay nasuri na natin kung ano ang mangyayari kapag pinatakbo natin ang algorithm ni Grover para sa T na ulit makukuha natin ang estado na
ipinapakita dito sa screen kaya dahil ang coefficient ng k A1 ay ang S
ng 2T + 1 * Theta kung saan muli narito ang napakahalagang anggulonng Theta
makikita natin ang solusyon na may posibilidad na sin^2 ng 2T +1 *
Theta gusto nating gawing malaki ang posibilidad na iyon na malapit sa isa hangga't maaari kaya habang inii-rotate natin ang estado
vector sa pamamagitan ng pag-ulit ng G iisipin natin ang k A1 bilang target na estado at susubukan nating
pumili ng T upang malapit tayo sa estadong ito at habang ginagawa natin ito ay mabuting tandaan na gusto rin naming
i-minimize ang T dahil iyon ang bilang ng mga query na kailangan naming gawin kaya kung gusto nating gawing
malaki ang posibilidad na ito na malapit sa isa at i-minimize ang T ay makatuwiran na subukang gawing malapit sa Pi / 2 ang anggulo ng ating estado vector dahil
iyon ang pinakamaliit na anggulo na nagpapagaling ng sine squared kaya ito ay ang ating unang pagkakataon na gawing malaki ang posibilidad habang ini-rotate natin
ang estado vector ngayon ay hindi natin kailangang tamaan nang eksakto ang anggulonng pi over 2 na ito dahil ang T ay kailangang
maging integer ngunit kung iniisip natin ito nang tinatayang at nilulutas para sa t na parang ito ay hindi pagkakatumbas makikita natin na ang perpektong
pagpili ng T na maging pi over 4 * Theta minus 12 ay
makatuwiran ngunit siyempre ang T ay dapat maging isang hindi negatibong integer kaya ang gagawin natin ay ang
kumuha ng pinakamalapit na integer sa ating iniisip na perpektong halaga na siyang floor ng pi na hinati ng 4 *
Theta ang pagkuha ng floor sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay nangangahulugan lang na itatapon natin ang anumang fractional na bahagi kaya sa madaling salita ito ay ang pinakamalaking
integer na mas mababa sa o katumbas ng anumang pinagkukuhaan ng floor ayon sa expression na ito kung ang
perpektong halaga ay mangyaring nasa pagitan ng mga integer ay magruraround up tayo ngunit hindi talaga iyon mahalaga para sa
layunin ng araling ito kaya sa pagtahak ay magtutuon tayo sa partikular na pagpiling ito ng
T ngunit mayroon isa pang mahalagang konsiderasyon na kailangan nating gawin na ang tinutukoy ng T na ito ay depende
sa kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon dahil ang anggulonng Theta ay depende sa bilang ng
mga solusyon mula rito ay gagamitin ko ang titik s para sumangguni sa bilang ng mga solusyon o sa madaling salita ang laki ng
set na a one para lang sa kapakinabangan ng kaginhawaan anyway ang punto ay ang ating
expression para sa T ang halaga na ating inaakala na dapat maging mabuti ay depende sa Theta at ang Theta ay depende sa S na siyang
laki ng set na A1 hindi ito problema kung alam natin nang maaga kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon ngunit
kung hindi natin alam nang maaga kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon ay hindi natin alam kung ano ang Theta kaya hindi natin mapipili ang T nang ganito
at kailangan nating gumawa ng ibang bagay babalikan ko ang sitwasyong kung saan hindi natin alam ang s nang kaunti pa sa bandang huli ngunit para
magsimula ay ituon natin ang pansin sa sitwasyong kung saan alam natin kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon simula sa natatanging paghahanap
kung saan may garantiya na may iisang natatanging solusyon na hinahanap
natin binanggit ko ang natatanging search problem bilang halimbawa ng isang query problem noong aralin
lima ang input ay isang function na f mula sa nbits hanggang sa isang bit mayroon isang natatanging n bit
string na nagpapasuri sa F sa isa at ang layunin ay i-output ang string na iyon kaya
ito ay katumbas ng unstructured search problem na pinag-usapan natin ngunit may pangako na may eksaktong isang solusyon at sa katunayan ito ay
ang tanging bersyon ng search problem na isinaalang-alang ni Grover sa kanyang orihinal na papel noong 1996 na nagpakilala ng algorithm ni Grover
para sa natatanging paghahanap mayroon tayo na ang s ay katumbas ng 1 at samakatuwid ang mahalagang anggulonng Theta ay katumbas ng inverse sine
ng square root ng 1 n kapag ang n ay malaki ang halaga na ito ay humigit-kumulang na square root ng 1/ N at
iyon ay dahil para sa mas maliit at mas maliliit na anggulo ang sine function ay nagsisimulang magmukhang higit at higit pa katulad ng identity
function kung isu-substitute natin ang approximation na iyon sa ating pagpili para sa T makikita natin na ang t ay humigit-kumulang ang floor
ng pi over 4 * ang square root ng n maganda iyon dahil nasa tamang landas tayo para gumamit ng Big O ng square root ng n
query kahit na sa puntong ito ay hindi pa nating nakikita nang eksakto kung gaano kahusay gumaganap ang algorithm
tingnan natin ang isang halimbawa kung saan ang malaking N ay 128 na siyang 2 ^ 7 kaya
ang ating function na f ay mula sa pitong bit hanggang sa isang bit at inaakala nating mayroon isang natatanging solusyon ngunit upang malaman kung
gaano kahusay gumaganap ang algorithm kailangan lang nating alalahanin ang anggulonng Theta na maaari nating kalkulahin ito ay
humigit-kumulang 0.08 85 radians na kaunti mahigit sa 5° at kung i-plug natin ang halagang iyon sa ating
expression para sa T ay makukuha natin ang walo kaya nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa kung ano ang mangyayari kapag naghahanap tayo ng natatanging solusyon sa labas ng 128
posibilidad gamit ang walong query maaari tayong gumuhit ng larawan upang mailarawan kung paano nagbabago ang estado sa paglipas ng
panahon habang nagsasagawa tayo ng mga ulit ng grover operation tulad ng dati mayroon tayo ng mga estado na k
a0 at k A1 at sa partikular na kasong ito na ibig sabihin ay natatanging paghahanap mayroon tayo na ang kat A1 ay sa katunayan ang standard basis state
na katumbas ng natatanging solusyon anuman ang mangyari well ang k a0 ay ang uniform superposition sa lahat ng
string maliban sa natatanging solusyon narito ang uniform superposition sa lahat ng string na
maaari nating isulat bilang cosine Theta k a0 kasama ang sin Theta k A1 at makatuwiran na ang k a0
at k U ay malapit sa kasong ito dahil tulad ng naobserbahan natin kaunti lang ang nakaraang sandali ang k a0 ay
halos ang uniform superposition sa lahat ng string iisang string lang ang nawawala at iyon ay ang natatanging solusyon ang pag-apply ng G muli ay inii-rotate ng karagdagang
2 Theta kaya narito tayo pagkatapos ng dalawang ulit narito ang tatlo apat lima anim pito at walo
at ngayon ay makikita natin na malapit na tayo sa kat A1 kaya kung titigil tayo at susukat sa puntong ito ay malamang na makuha natin ang
natatanging solusyon at sa katunayan sa kasong ito ay mayroon lang humigit-kumulang kalahating porsyentong pagkakataon na hindi natin makuha ang natatanging
solusyon sa kabilang banda kung magpapatuloy tayo na mag-apply ng grover operation nang higit sa inirerekomendang walong beses
ang posibilidad na makakuha ng solusyon ay bababa muli at sa paglipas ng panahon ay mag-o-oscillate habang ang estado ay umiikot sa
bilog kaya mahalaga na huminto tayo sa mga ulit sa tamang oras kung gusto nating magtagumpay nang may mataas na
posibilidad pag-isipan natin ang posibilidad na ang ating pagpili para sa T ay mabubunyag ang natatanging solusyon nang mas pangkalahatan para sa iba't ibang halaga ng
n isusulat natin ang pn1 upang tukuyin ang posibilidad na ang algorithm ni Grover ay nagtagumpay sa paghanap ng natatanging solusyon
para sa bawat posibleng halaga ng n ang isa ay nangangahulugang isang solusyon at papalawiin natin ang notasyong ito sa iba pang mga bilang ng solusyon
sa lalong madaling panahon narito ang isang talahanayan ng mga posibilidad na ito para sa maliliit na kapangyarihan ng dalawa nagsisimula ito sa n katumbas ng 2 at ang
posibilidad ay 1/2 na hindi masyadong maganda ngunit pagkatapos para sa n katumbas ng 4 ang posibilidad ay eksaktong isa kaya epektibo itong gumagana
nang perpekto sa kasong ito ito ay isang napakagandang ehersisyo sa pamamagitan ng paraan na hayagang dumaan sa kung paano gumagana ang dalawang kasong ito
lalo na ang kaso na ang n ay katumbas ng apat sa kasong iyon ay naghahanap tayo ng isang solusyon sa labas ng apat na posibilidad
kailangan lang natin ng iisang query at gumagana ito nang perpekto habang nagiging mas malaki ang n makikita natin ang ilang pagbabago-bago ang mga posibilidad ay
tumaas at bumaba nang kaunti ngunit mukhang lumalapit ang mga ito sa isa at talagang totoo iyon maaaring patunayan
nang analytical na ang posibilidad ay palagi ay hindi bababa sa 1 - 1 / n kaya maganda iyon
ang algorithm ay hindi perpekto hindi tayo garantisadong makakakuha ng solusyon ngunit ito ay medyo malamang lalo na para sa malalaking
halaga ng n pati na rin ang napakainteresanteng anomaliya na nangyayari kapag ang n ay katumbas ng 4
dapat ko ring ituro na maaari nating palaging patakbuhin ang buong algorithm kasama ang mga sukat nang maraming beses hangga't gusto natin at kung ang kahit isa sa mga takbo
ay nagtagumpay ay makakakuha tayo ng solusyon kaya kung ang mga posibilidad na ito ay hindi sapat ay madali nating mapalalaki ang mga ito sa pamamagitan lang ng pagpapatakbo ulit ng
algorithm sa katunayan kahit na ang lahat ng mga posibilidad na ito ay katumbas ng 1/2 halimbawa ay magkakaroon pa rin tayo ng
kapaki-pakinabang na searching algorithm ngayon ay isaalang-alang natin kung ano ang mangyayari kapag mayroon ng maramihang
solusyon magsisimula tayo sa katulad na halimbawa tulad ng dati muli ang n ay katumbas ng 128 ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ang
bilang ng mga solusyon na s ay apat sa halip na 1 muli ay maaari nating kalkulahin ang Theta at ang T at
makukuha natin na ang Theta ay humigit-kumulang 01777 o kaunti mahigit sa 10° at ang T ay
apat sa pagkakataong ito kaya ang anggulo ay humigit-kumulang dalawang beses ng halaga mula sa nakaraang halimbawa at ang T ay kalahati ng dati
maaari tayong gumuhit ng larawan tulad ng dati narito ang simula natin
narito ang isang ulit dalawa tatlo at apat sa pagkakataong ito ay napalapit na tayo sa kat
A1 at ang posibilidad na makakuha ng solusyon sa pagkakataong ito ay lumabas na mas malaki kaysa sa
99.9% ngunit kung hindi tayo maalam at naisip natin na may isang solusyon lang ay kukuha tayo ng T na maging 8 tulad ng
dati at mag-i-rotate tayo nang halos buong paraan paikot patungo sa negative k a0 at iyon ay hahantong sa napakaliit na posibilidad ng
tagumpay kaya iyon ay isang karagdagang halimbawa na nagpapakita na mayroong magagandang pagpipilian ng T at masamang pagpipilian ng T at dito ay makikita natin
na ang isang magandang pagpipilian para sa S katumbas ng 1 ay lumabas na napakamaling pagpipilian para sa S katumbas ng 4 ngunit sa pagpapalagay na alam natin ang s nang
maaga at pipiliin natin ang T ayon sa ating tinutukoy ay lalabas na ang algorithm ni Grover ay makakahanap ng solusyon
na may posibilidad na hindi bababa sa 1 - x over n at madalas ay magiging mas malaki pa kaysa sa iyon ito ay hindi bababa sa s Over N din ngunit
iyon ay talagang mas hindi kawili-wili ang mas kawili-wili ay habang ang fraction na s Over N ay nagiging maliit ang hangganan
sa posibilidad ng tagumpay ay lalapit at lalapit sa isa ngayon tulad ng nabanggit ko nang ilang beses
ang bilang na T ay kumakatawan hindi lamang sa bilang ng mga ulit ng grover operation na ginagawa natin kundi pati na rin sa bilang
ng mga query na ginagawa natin kaya paano depende ang bilang na ito sa s at
n una ay simulan natin sa katotohanang ang inverse sine ng X ay palagi ay hindi bababa sa X sa kondisyon na ang X ay nasa pagitan ng Z at 1
medyo madaling ipakita iyon kung sakaling alam mo ang tailor series para sa inverse sine function ngunit may ibang mga paraan para mapag-isipan ito at
kukuha lang natin ito bilang ibinigay dahil ito ay totoo iyon ay nangangahulugan na ang Theta ay hindi bababa sa square root ng s/
n at dahil doon ang T ay hindi hihigit sa square root ng pi / 4 * ng square root ng n /
s kaya iyon ay talagang mas mahusay pa kaysa sa Big O ng root n habang mas malaki ang s
kumpara sa n ay mas kaunting mga query ang kailangan nating gawin at sa isang paraan ay hindi nakakagulat na lalabas ang fraction na ito
nang ganito dahil ang reciprocal nito ay nagtatakda ng Theta at sa katapusan ng araw ang Theta ay talagang ang lahat ng mahalaga para sa
pagsusuring ito tulad ng nakita natin kamakailan ay gumagana nang mabuti ang algorithm ni Grover kapag alam natin
nang maaga kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon ngunit paano kung hindi natin alam kung ilang solusyon ang
mayroon mayroon isang medyo simpleng diskarte at iyon ay ang piliin lang ang bilang ng mga ulit
nang random at partikular ang pagpili ng T nang random na pantay sa pagitan ng isa at ang floor ng pi over 4 * root n ay lumabas na
medyo magandang paraan para gawin ito ang itaas na dulo ng hanay na ito ay humigit-kumulang ang bilang ng mga query na pipiliin natin para sa natatanging paghahanap at sa katunayan
eksaktong tamang bilang sa karamihan ng mga kaso ito ay kapag ang anggulonng Theta ay kasing liit ng posible na hindi kasama ang
trivial na kaso kapag walang mga solusyon ang ideya dito ay sa halip na maingat na ituturo ang ating estado vector sa
k A1 tulad ng ginawa natin nang alam natin kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon ay nagbibigay tayo ng random na pag-ikot sa estado vector na para bang
binibigyan lang natin ng random na spin ang estado vector kung may isang solusyon lang ay ang ating random spin ay maaaring itulak ang
estado vector na malapit sa k A1 ngunit maaari rin itong matupad lang ng bahagya at kung may maraming solusyon ang
ating random spin ay maaaring magpadala ng estado vector sa buong bilog nang maraming beses kaya hindi natin inaasahan na mabubunyag nito ang
solusyon na may posibilidad na malapit sa isa ngunit ang pagkakataon na humantong ito sa solusyon kung mayroon man ay lumabas na
medyo maganda ito ay palagi ay hindi bababa sa 40% sa katunayan hindi iyon halata ngunit ito ay ang
kaso tiyak na hindi ito nakakagulat gayunpaman dahil ang isang tunay na random na anggulo ay magkakaroon ng 50% na pagkakataon na makahanap ng
solusyon anyway ang 40% ay hindi masama at tandaan na maaari tayong palaging palakihin ang posibilidad ng paghanap ng solusyon sa pamamagitan ng
pag-ulit ng proseso na pinipili ang T nang hiwalay sa bawat pagkakataon sa paggawa nito ang mga pagkakataon ng hindi
paghanap ng solusyon kapag mayroon man ay bumababa nang exponentially sa bilang ng mga beses na umuulit tayo kaya kung gusto nating magkaroon ng 99%
na pagkakataon na makahanap ng solusyon ang maaari nating gawin ay ang patakbuhin ang simpleng diskarteng ito nang 10 beses muli na may t na pinili nang hiwalay sa bawat
pagkakataon natural kung hindi tayo makakahanap ng solusyon ay nag-o-output tayo ng walang mga solusyon kung walang mga solusyon
ay hindi tayo makakahanap ng isa at kaya sa kasong iyon ay palagi tayong mag-o-output ng tamang sagot na walang mga solusyon kung mayroon mga solusyon
ay maaaring mabigo tayong mahanap ang isa at maling magdeklara na walang mga solusyon ngunit ang posibilidad na mangyari iyon ay maaaring gawing napakaliit
mayroon din tayo tulad ng nabanggit ko kaunti pa ang nakaraang sandali na nangangailangan ito ng bilang ng mga query o pagsusuri ng f na Big O ng root
n kaya gamit ang algorithm ni Grover ay maaari pa rin nating malutas ang search problem nang may mataas na posibilidad na may Big O ng root end
query kahit hindi natin alam nang maaga kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon mayroon din mas sopistikadong
diskarte na maaaring humantong sa pagbabawas ng bilang ng mga query habang lumalaki ang bilang ng mga solusyon hindi ko ito ilarawan sa
detalye gayunpaman at sa halip ay magtutuon lang ako sa pangunahing ideya nagsisimula tayo sa malaking T na katumbas ng
isa pagkatapos ay pinapatakbo natin ang algorithm ni Grover para sa random na bilang ng mga ulit ngunit kung saan ang itaas na hangganan ay T kaya ang una
pagkakataon na dumating tayo sa hakbang dalawa ay magpapatakbo tayo ng algorithm ni Grover na may isang ulit ngunit ang T ay magiging
lumalaki kung makahanap tayo ng solusyon ay i-o-output natin ang solusyon na iyon at titigil tayo at kung hindi natin mahahanap ang solusyon ay gagawin nating mas
malaki ang t at susubukan ulit at sa ilang punto bago maging masyadong malaki ang T ay ihihinto natin ang proseso at
magdedeklara tayo na walang mga solusyon ito ay parehong pangunahing ideya tulad ng mayroon tayo sa simpleng diskarte kung saan
nagbibigay tayo ng random na spin sa estado vector sa esensya ngunit dito ay nagsisimula tayo sa mas magaan na spin muna kung saan ang T ay
maliit sakaling maraming solusyon sa ganitong paraan hindi tayo mag-aaksaya ng mga query sa pamamagitan ng pagpapaliko ng estado nang
paulit-ulit sa bilog sa pamamagitan ng masyadong malakas na pag-spin ngunit kung hindi ito gumagana na ibig sabihin ay hindi tayo makakahanap ng solusyon ay susubukan nating muli
ngunit mag-i-spin tayo nang kaunti pang mas malakas o potensyal na kaunti pang mas malakas upang mapagana ito ang rate ng
pagtaas ng T ay kailangang piliin nang maingat at isang paraan upang mapagana ito ay ang palitan ang T ng ceiling ng 54s times T
kaya ang T ay nadaragdagan nang exponentially at sa intuition ay maaari nating isipin ito bilang pag-spin nang 25% nang mas malakas sa bawat
pagkakataon at mahalaga para sa pagsusuri na ang t ay dumarami nang exponentially nang ganito bakit 54s maaari kang magtanong well ito ay
isang numero lang na gumagana at mayroon talagang hanay ng mga halaga na gumagana ngunit dalawa ay hindi gumagana halimbawa ang pagdoble ng T
sa bawat pagkakataon ay masyadong mabilis ang pagtaas upang samantalahin nang ganap ang mga benepisyo ng mas magaan na mga spin anyway ang punto ng mas
sopistikadong pamamaraang ito ay nagbibigay ito ng parehong asymptotic na hangganan sa bilang ng mga query na kinakailangan natin tulad ng dati
Big O ng square root ng n / s ngunit hindi natin kailangan na malaman nang maaga kung ilang solusyon ang mayroon at sa pamamagitan ng paraan
ay maaari nating ihinto ang prosesong ito kapag ang T ay umabot sa root n kaya kung walang mga solusyon ay maaabot natin ang konklusyon na iyon pagkatapos ng bigo
ng root end na mga query at iyon ay kung paano natin maaaring piliin ang bilang ng mga ulit sa algorithm ni Grover upang tapusin ang aralin ay
gagawa lang ako ng ilang maikling puna tungkol sa algorithm ni Grover una sa loob ng query model
ang algorithm ni Grover ay asymptotically optimal ang ibig sabihin nito ay hindi posible na gumawa ng
query algorithm para sa paglutas ng search problem o kahit ng natatanging search problem nang partikular na gumagamit ng asymptotically
mas kaunti kaysa sa Big O ng root end na mga query sa pinakamasamang kaso iyon ay isang bagay na maaaring patunayan nang mahigpit
at mayroon talagang maraming kilalang patunay ng katotohanang ito kapansin-pansin ito ay kilala na kahit
bago natuklasan ang algorithm ni Grover ang algorithm ni Grover ay tumugma sa nang kilala na mas mababang hangganan sa bilang ng
mga query na kinakailangan paminsan-minsan ang mga tao ay nagmumungkahi ng mga diskarte na sa kanilang paniniwala ay asymptotically
na mas mahusay kaysa sa algorithm ni Grover ngunit palagi ay may pagkakamali o pagpapalagay tungkol sa function na f at
kung paano ito maa-access o ilang iba pang may problemang isyu na nagpapababa ng katumpakan ng pahayag kung nagtatrabaho ka nang tama
sa loob ng query model ay hindi mo matatalo ang algorithm ni Grover para sa unstructured search pangalawa ang algorithm ni Grover ay
medyo malawak na angkop sa kahulugan na ang square root na bilis na inaalok ng algorithm ni Grover para sa unstructured search problem ay maaaring
makamit sa iba't ibang mga setting halimbawa minsan ay posible na gamitin ang algorithm ni Grover sa
ibabaw ng isa pang algorithm upang makakuha ng quadratic na pagpapabuti lampas sa pagganap ng algorithm na iyon ang algorithm ni Grover ay
medyo karaniwan ring ginagamit bilang isang subroutine sa loob ng iba pang Quantum algorithm bilang isang simpleng halimbawa
maaari nating gamitin ang algorithm ni Grover upang makakuha ng quadratic na kalamangan kumpara sa mga klasikal na algorithm para sa minimum problem na nabanggit ko sa
aralin lima at sa wakas ang teknik na ginamit sa algorithm ni Grover kung saan mayroon tayong dalawa
na refleksyon na kinokompose at inuulit upang umiikot ng isang Quantum state vector ay maaaring mapalawig sa isang medyo
malaking paraan isang halimbawa ay isang teknik na kilala bilang amplitude amplification kung saan ang isang proseso
na nagpapalawig ng algorithm ni Grover ay maaaring ilapat sa isa pang quantum algorithm upang mahalagang palakasin ang posibilidad ng tagumpay nito nang quadratically na mas mabilis kaysa sa
posible nang klasikal at ang teknik na iyon ay may malawak na aplikasyon sa Quantum algorithms kaya maaaring totoo na ang
algorithm ni Grover ay malamang na hindi hahantong sa praktikal na Quantum advantage sa lalong madaling panahon kung mayroon man ngunit ang algorithm ni Grover ay
walang alinlangan na isang pundamental na mahalaga at malawak na angkop na Quantum algorithm at ito ay kinakatawan ng mas pangkalahatang teknik na may maraming
gamit at iyon na ang huli para sa araling ito at para sa yunit na ito ng serye na tungkol sa Quantum
algorithm napag-usapan natin ang query model at kung paano natin ito maikonekta sa mas karaniwang modelo ng computation kasama ang
ilang ibang pangunahing konsepto tungkol sa kung paano natin masusukat ang computational cost at pagkatapos ay tinakpan natin ang phase estimation
at factoring at pagkatapos sa wakas ang algorithm ni Grover tulad ng iminungkahi ko na
marami pang matututunan tungkol sa Quantum algorithm ngunit sa seryeng ito ay lilipat tayo sa ibang paksa sa susunod na yunit lalo na ay titingnan natin ang
pangkalahatang formulation ng quantum information kung saan ang mga Quantum state ay kinakatawan ng mga matrix ng isang tiyak
na uri na kilala bilang mga density matrix tulad ng makikita natin ang formulation na ito ay nagiging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang at talagang
mahalaga para sa pag-unawa ng ilang aspeto ng quantum information at nagkataon din na ito ay medyo maganda mula sa isang
mathematical na pananaw kaya sana ay sasama ka sa akin para sa yunit tatlo at paalam hanggang sa
susunod